foreign
[Music]
characters Flex their strength on their
opponents faces Jiu Jitsu Kaizen is a
popular manga an anime series that
revolves around the world of sorcery and
curses with a diverse cast of powerful
characters it's no surprise that the
series is filled with countless epic and
awe-inspiring moments from the deadliest
One-Shot attacks in all of anime to
Godly animated fight scenes prepare to
be amazed by the top 10 biggest Flexes
in Jiu Jitsu Kaizen first on our list is
the scene that showed us jjk isn't
another run-of-the-mill Shonen nobona
and itadori's black flash
dead
it's not right not many characters in
anime can be called executioners so when
the female character nobara switch
flipped she was a menace from start to
finish what makes her fight with the
cursed womb brother so cold is how she
counted their curse technique with her
own and how she and itadori completely
turned the table on the brothers who
positively thought they'd already won
nobara being a witty and resourceful
Jujitsu sorcerer and fails her Ultimate
Weapon the straw doll technique during a
battle against the curse Brothers Esso
and gechizu by using this technique she
summons a straw doll linked to her own
body and inflicts damage upon the dolls
causing a corresponding effect on her
enemies this moment showcases novara's
creativity and her ability to adapt to
dangerous situations during the whole
fight she was a complete Menace and
seeing itadori blow of esso's arm was
gold with just one punch that double
black flash by itadori and nobara was
the cherry on top
next up it's not rare in anime to see a
character with copy abilities and it's
also not surprising that jjk has one so
we have Utah using the curse speech
technique
what makes this moment a hard Flex for
Utah was that he only trained and
learned about cursed energy for almost
half a year and yet in such a short
amount of time he was able to copy and
perform a technique that had serious
side effects on the user it was nothing
even inumaki who trained his whole life
has to be careful when he uses his curse
technique a new digest use one of the
most dangerous words without even
flinching while everyone lost
inexplicably to ghetto here we have a
newbie in the Jiu Jitsu world going
against the man considered to be Gojo's
rival how you duster on that pole and
how ghetto's minions exploded as soon as
you thought uttered the words die was a
breathtaking scene that you absolutely
must watch this is one of those Let's
ignore all the rules moments in anime
that will leave you on the edge of your
seat
disrespecting fodder is one thing but
disrespecting a special grade spirit is
another we have sukuna versus special
grade Cur spirit
everything
apart from Gojo sukuna for over a
thousand years has maintained his title
as the king of curses and for a reason
he's an absolute Powerhouse in his own
right now his fight against this special
grade cursed Spirit was just a sneak
peek at how strong he truly is looking
back this same curse Spirit was toying
with itadori while megumi and nobara
made their escape but as soon as tsukuna
appeared the curse Spirit knew suguna
meant business seeing how scared it was
keep in mind that saguna wasn't at full
power just yet but Sweating Bullets was
a natural reaction if you encountered
the king of curses yourself throughout
this whole scene seguna was just flexing
his abilities only two fingers consumed
saguna completely decimated the special
grade cursed spirit with ease the cat
was so huge the seguna who only thought
of slicing the spirit in three using his
domain expansion ended up splitting it
into six pieces if you're a man who held
the title of king of curses for a
thousand years they don't call you a
special grade curse Spirits they call
you Rio man saguna which team
[Music]
moving on we get to see one of the
sickest combos in anime itadori's
consecutive black flash
okay thanks
[Music]
black flash is like a once in a lifetime
buff for jjk Sorcerers some are lucky
enough to use it more than once although
not consecutively it's even said that
the difference between those who
experience black flash and those who
haven't is Like Heaven and Earth how
itadori poured in all his concentration
just to unlock black flash even amazed
his opponent he was laser focused to the
point that it made him drool but in a
split second all hell broke loose for
Hanami as itadori landed his first ever
black flash itadori didn't stop with
just one later in the fight as things
were heating up itadori landed four more
consecutive black flashes I mean why
stop at one then you could do four more
even Toto was surprised that either Dori
was able to land all those black flashes
in one go he broke the record for the
most numerous consecutive black flashes
which was held by nanami what made that
Flex so amazing was perhaps the
animation of the fight how everything
was done was just perfect down to every
minute detail
next up we have one of the most
dangerous One-Shot attacks in all of
anime Gojo uses Hollow purple on Hanami
foreign
Gojo casually says he'll be a little
rough and proceeds to show us why even
special great care Spirits are afraid of
him in one attack called Hollow purple
Gojo drills a hole and obliterates
everything that's in front of him this
technique combines his red and blue
techniques where it basically removes
whatever it touches from existence you
have to take note that both Toto and
Yuji were unable to kill Hanami even if
they were in their own Flow State and
with just Hollow purple Gojo ended the
entire fight he just does One Flex after
another and proceeds to do it in one of
the most destructive ways possible the
animation was pristine and the studio
was on point when they added that
background music you can never not call
this a flex because Hollow purple was so
strong that it made a cliff and they
didn't even know if the cursed Spirit
was exercised or not because there's
just nothing left
taking the fifth spot the world's
strongest sorcerer against a newly
reincarnated king of curses Gojo versus
sukuna
for 10 short seconds we see how Gojo
flexed his strength against the king of
curses sukuna was taken back when he
realized Gojo was sitting on him but he
was on all fours down on the ground as
they fought Gojo felt the need to tell
saguna he needed to show off to impress
his student and so for 10 seconds sukuna
became Gojo's toy and megumi was just
looking at how Gojo disrespected sukuna
the newly reincarnated king of curses
was thrown around like a ragdoll by Gojo
making a mockery out of him as the 10
seconds ticked away this moment was so
satisfying for one reason the
one-sidedness of the fight sukuna
wouldn't be able to get back a Gojo for
this humiliation for a very long time or
so we thought
good job
[Music]
up next we have another Gojo beat down
this time it's Gojo versus Miguel
apart from youth are using inumaki's
curse speech in the movie the fight
between the strongest sorcerer Gojo
against Miguel was also a flex in its
own right I've seen a lot of one-sided
anime fights but this has got to be the
top 10 amongst them all although Miguel
was told to only distract Gojo he never
dreamed that he'd try that hard at
running away it was all hands from Gojo
since the beginning of their fight the
more Miguel tried to run away the more
he received the beating of a lifetime I
personally didn't know what Miguel did
to offend Gojo that much but it was just
painful to watch the fight was
choreographed so well that for two
minutes if Miguel wasn't trying to run
away he was catching Gojo's hands what
makes this moment so satisfying is
seeing how Miguel's confidence was
destroyed as he realized how badly he
messed up even if he had the black rope
which cancels other curse techniques it
comes in contact with
oh
Gojo makes another consecutive
appearance with Gojo vs jogo
here we see yet another poor soul that
was embarrassed by none other than Gojo
himself jogo being the cursed Spirit he
is took pride in his strength and how
they were the true humans instead of The
Fakes that run rampant in the world
arrogantly facing off against the goat
he quickly learns that Gojo's title is
the strongest wasn't a baseless rumor
and he learns this lesson the hard way
Gojo didn't spare a single moment in
teaching yoga what it meant to challenge
someone way above your league and the
way Gojo smirked and told him that he
was weak was a big slap to jogo's face
this moment was so satisfying because
prior to this jogo was brimming with
confidence saying that he could beat the
goat with ease and boy he was absolutely
wrong from his attacks not even touching
Gojo to the point where Gojo took
itadori to make this fight a teaching
moment jogo was disrespected to a whole
other level luckily for jogo his comrade
Hanami saved him at the very last minute
as he was already on the verge of death
after Gojo pulled his head from his body
all right
coming in hot at number two is the
moment the world's strongest sorcerer
Falls and his win streak ends
foreign
despite not having cursed energy toji
fushiguro was blessed with insane
physical capabilities making him a force
to be reckoned with toji isn't known as
the sorcerer killer for nothing he's
like the Dulux version of Maki zenin
he's faster and stronger in so many ways
toji was always one step ahead of Gojo
during their initial fight and the Goat
was ultimately killed by getting stabbed
right in the neck but not before toji
massacred him in one of the most
animated one-sided fights in anime Gojo
even destroyed almost every building
surrounding them but toji was just too
smart and just too fast being able to
kill one of the strongest individuals in
the verse with relative ease is a feat
that's worth praise and to do it without
cursed energy purely relying on only
tactics and physical capabilities is a
testament to toji fushiguro's strength
and battle IQ but itoji actually killed
Gojo or did he help him even more
[Music]
taking the number one spot is the
rematch between the goat and toji
fushiguro Gojo vs toji round two
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
Gojo refuses to yield and comes back to
life pushing his capabilities to newer
Heights coming back stronger than before
this was all like after I said toji
disrespected him in round one and the
next encounter it was all Gojo's moment
to shine laughing like a maniac Gojo
proceeded to show toji the huge
difference between them especially
noting that Gojo knows the reverse cast
technique to heal himself that it
happened Gojo revealed his hollow purple
technique to toji which finished their
encounter in a Flash in one shot toji
fushiguro's Legacy comes to an end he
never fails to live up to his reputation
throughout the heavens and earth he
alone is the honored one the goat Gojo
satoru
music
and there you have it the top 10 biggest
flexors in Jiu Jitsu Kaizen along with a
special mention although there are bound
to be some flexes that I've missed let
me know what you think in the comment
section below and don't forget to like
share and subscribe